we'll probably never know the reasons
for the death of every character who's
died on a TV show but some stories from
the behind the scenes just couldn't stay
under wraps here are some of the most
scandalous reasons some well-known TV
characters kicked a fictional bucket
shannen doherty is arguably better known
for being difficult to work with than
she is for her acting after Tori
Spelling witness would look like a
fistfight between her and Jennie Garth
on the set of nine oh two unknown she
asked her father producer Aaron Spelling
to fire Authority just a few years later
however Aaron Spelling surprisingly cast
Dority in another project the WB
supernatural drama charmed history
repeated itself Doherty quit the show in
2001 after reports of a feud with
co-star Alyssa Milano after season 3
cliffhanger that left her character's
fate in jeopardy
the season 4 opener revealed that the
character had died I don't understand
why magic can't fix this Quay can't
bring Prue back it's not like we haven't
cheated death before I don't understand
why this time is any different see our
night left Grey's Anatomy in 2009 after
five seasons despite the fact that his
character young dr. George O'Malley was
a fan favorite Knight knew something was
up with the show's first nine episodes
of the 2008 oh 9 season when he landed
only 48 minutes of screen time less than
half of co-star Sandra Oh rather than
ask producer Shonda Rhimes just what was
happening he walked away instead he told
Entertainment Weekly my five year
experience proved to me that I cannot
trust any answer that was given and with
respect I'm going to leave it at that
perhaps he angered Rhimes his horrific
death can certainly imply that he's hit
by a bus admitted to the very hospital
where he worked and after his doctor
friends finally recognized him he's
pronounced brain dead and passes away
one of the biggest news shows of the
2004 o-5 season was also among the most
innovative ABC's time and mind-bending
desert-island sci-fi adventure series
lost many of its cast became stars in
the show won the Emmy for Outstanding
Drama Series but some actors on the show
didn't enjoy the process of making the
series Adewale akinnuoye-agbaje who
played the mysterious and conflicted
nigerian priest mr. Eko
left this series in season 3 why well
while this might be hard to believe
a Kanoa Abaza hated filming in Hawaii he
asked to leave the show and long-term
plans for mr. Eko would cancel the
character was killed off a victim of the
smoke monster
eko wasn't the only character killed off
the beloved sci-fi show from the outside
it appeared that the lost characters Ana
Lucia Cortez and Libby Smith portrayed
by Michelle Rodriguez and Cynthia watt
Rose met their ends due to off-screen
misbehavior during the middle of the
show's second season both actresses were
arrested on suspicion of drunk driving
and failed sobriety tests not long after
both characters died in actuality they
were arrested in effect the show at all
in an interview with TV Guide lost
co-creator Damon Lindelof said that the
characters deaths had already been
written in the case of Ana Lucia Cortez
Michelle Rodriguez only wanted to do one
season of the show anyhow the fact that
their character also happened to die at
the same time as watch Rose Libby was
just a coincidence Seinfeld's occasional
callous cruelty was part of the appeal
of the show but the show I did itself in
one episode when it killed off a major
reoccurring character George Costanza
fiancee Susan Ross died at the end of
the seventh season having ingested a
toxic amount of glue from licking
wedding invitation envelopes oh she's
dead yes huh apparently George who'd
wanted out of the engagement wasn't the
only one happy to hear the news of the
character's death in an interview with
Howard Stern several years later after
Jason Alexander revealed that the
actress Heidi Swedberg just didn't sync
up with him her instincts for doing a
scene where the comedy was and mine were
always misfiring he wasn't the only one
on set who felt that way
Alexander related how his co-star Julia
louis-dreyfus agreed with him casually
remarking don't you want to just kill
her once Ryder Larry David heard this
that was the end of Susan Ross poor
Carla Tortelli just when it looked like
she finally found true love with hockey
player Eddie Lebec the poor doofus went
and got himself killed while shears was
generally one of the more reserved
comedies on television during its
11-year run the writers scratched their
wacky itch when it came time to kill
Eddie he's killed in a bizarre Zamboni
accident setting up a wacky chain of
events that led to Carla meeting Eddie
secret other wife during the funeral in
2006
Cheers writer ken levine revealed on his
blog just why they killed off Eddie
Lebec
and in such a perplexing way actor Jay
Thomas who also worked as a radio DJ
responded to a caller asked him how it
felt to act on Cheers
Levine would call Thomas making some
distasteful remarks about his co-star
it's brutal I have to kiss Rhea Perlman
that got him fired Anna got Lavigne and
riding partner David Isaac's too right
Eddie Lebec bizarre death while house
had its lighter moments it could get
pretty dark too one example the fate of
eager diagnostic medicine fella Lawrence
Kutner the character had to make a hasty
exit when actor Cowpen embarked on a
political career partway through the
show's run in 2009 taking a job with the
brand-new Obama administration not
wanting to pass up the opportunity to
bring a bit of drama out of his
departure the show's writers opted to
have Kutner commit suicide chilling as
that n may have been it seems there were
no hard feelings between the actor and
the showrunners pen came back to reprise
his role as Kutner for houses series
finale in the form of a hallucination
the only character to appear in every
episode of the original Dallas jr. Ewing
was famously shot in the cliffhanger
episode a house divided which left
America wondering who shot jr. all
summer though he survived the
assassination attempt a second shooter
finally fell the infamous oil man during
the second season of the series 2010's
revival on TNT while the plot twist
could have served as a shocking and
clever call back to the original show's
most famous moment writers had to
include it out of necessity Larry Hagman
who played jr. Ewing on both series lost
his battle to cancer in November 2012
Dallas 2.0 was still in production
forcing the creative staff to both
explain his sudden absence while also
hurriedly writing the character off the
show the end came with the Furious and
the fast which aired several months
after hagman's death and used
pre-existing footage to cobble together
his characters exit story John Francis
Daley was part of the cast of Fox's
long-running procedural drama bones from
almost the beginning but not until the
end
as dr. Lance sweets daily played a
psychologist in a behavior expert who
helped the crime fighters of the series
and their investigations over the years
daily developed a second career as one
of the most sought-after comedy
screenwriters in Hollywood working on
the scripts for Horrible Bosses the
incredible Burt Wonderstone and Cloudy
with a Chance of Meatballs 2 in 2014
Daly was offered the chance to not only
write the new national lampoon's
vacation but to direct it as well Daly
asked for a few months off from bones to
do the movie but the writers couldn't
think of a good way to explain a
prolonged absence
so his character took a bullet from the
bad guy and died
Josh Charles was a huge part of why the
Good Wife turned in such a compelling
drama each week his character will
Gardner was a brilliant attorney in the
show's courtroom scenes and he was also
a foil in romantic interest for Alicia
Florrick that and the fact that The Good
Wife didn't usually contain a lot of
violence meant it was pretty shocking
when will was brutally shot in a
courtroom scene in a 2014 episode in his
home but creators Robert and Michelle
King didn't have any animosity towards
Charles before the 2013-14 season began
Charles knew his contract would be up
and he let the Kings know that he wanted
to move on allowing them to plant an
explosive exit for well Charles
explained it all on The Late Show with
David Letterman I was just ready to kind
of move on I think it was great for the
show and also I think was a proper
goodbye to the character so that was
special character deaths were a
semi-regular occurrence on scandal
anyone who got caught up in the high
crimes and political machinations of
Olivia Pope generally saw their lifespan
decreased by a few years that included
her fellow fixers like Harrison Wright
played by Columbus Short like so many
other scandal standouts he went and got
himself killed by Olivia's evil father
Eli Pope a top secret CIA operative at
the end of season three of scandal
Harrison finds out eli killed a
president's son and it doesn't end well
for Harrison in April 2014
just days after the episode aired short
assured viewers that his character was
really dead he'd quit the show after
enduring his series of legal problems
short admitted on Access Hollywood live
that he'd left scandal due to a drug
issue
even after more than 30 years Shelly
long is still best known for her role as
Diane chambers on shears a show she
famously left in 1987 for her film
career she never became an a-list movie
star but she found one of her most
memorable gigs in the reoccurring role
of Dede Pritchett the emotionally
distant mother Claire and Mitchell on
Modern Family long prominently bound out
of the show - although this time it
wasn't her idea the modern family
writers just wanted to explore the
effects of death on the family before
the beginning of Modern Family's tenth
season in 2018 Show co-creator
Christopher Lloyd told Entertainment
Weekly that a significant character in
the show would die the death will be a
moving event and in an event that has
repercussions across several episodes on
the show's Halloween episode Claire gets
a call from her stepfather in which she
learns that Dede Pichette died in her
sleep the rest of the episode delves
into that impact okay are we gonna
handle this you mean because the two
most emotionally complicated people on
earth are facing the loss of the most
complicated relationship with their
lives check out one of our newest videos
right here plus even more looper videos
about your favorite stuff are coming
soon subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]